so you need a little uplift yeah you do  we've got it for you right here at eight  o'clock where we share stories that we  hope will bring you some joy to your  date jamie foxx is still not here but  jamie whack  baby came back jamie what do you have  for us that uplifted me yeah  we could all use  lifting up right now i've got a sweet  trick from a minnesota dad he found a  creative way to stop his two-year-old's  tantrum check this out  [Music]  little caroline borges came to the door  crying after her sister sprayed her with  water but dad quickly stopped those  tears not with a tissue but with some  whipped cream  right in the mouth caroline's mom says  two-year-olds can get upset over a lot  of things as we all know but her family  has found this trick works great i think  that is such a dad thing  i don't know a mom that would do that  i could see my wife doing it to me  that's a different story  just give the kids sugar it'll all be  okay jamie thank you that is sweet  though